- Have a seat.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Here's the thing.
I don't know a ton about sports ball,
but I do know you and I grew up on you
and there are so many
Texans here right now,
in this crew,
(the crew and audience cheers)
that you might get tackled at some point.
So just I'm giving you
a heads up.
- That's okay, yeah.
You're a Dallas girl.
- Yes, yes.
I'm a Fort Worth, but yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Awesome.
- Exactly, we are.
So wait, so you're not allowed
to say who will win the game.
- Yeah.
- I know that, okay.
(audience laughs)
- Well, I'm allowed to,
but I'm not going to, yeah.
- Oh, okay, okay, so why?
- Well, I call these games.
So I just, you know...
- You feel like it's favoritism?
- A little bit.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I try to be neutral.
And I wanna get along with
all the fan bases, so...
- No, totally.
But you think the Rams will win?
- Well, I do like the Rams.
(Kelly laughs)
I do like the Rams.
(audience cheering)
I do like the Rams and, you know,
Matthew Stafford, also a Dallas kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, he played
ball right there where I live,
but Joe Burrow with the
Bengals and what they've done,
I think that's been great for the NFL.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know, the fan base hasn't,
they haven't won a lot in Cincinnati,
so this has been fantastic.
So I think it's gonna
be a great Super Bowl.
(audience clapping)
- It would.
I'm just saying, it would be pretty cool
to be hosting the Super Bowl,
and then win the Super Bowl.
I'm just saying it'd be a good moment.
- It would be a great moment.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying.
- [Kelly] Throwing it out there.
- Yes.
- So wait, so I hear
that you're about to work
with Blake Shelton.
- Yes.
- Okay.
Well, do you want warnings,
or do you need help or
advice, or...? (laughs)
- Well, I love..
You all seem, and I don't
wanna speak for you,
but you seem like brothers
and sisters on that show.
The chemistry...
- We basically represent
Oklahoma and Texas, always at odds.
- Yeah.
- But yes.
- And he's been..
So, I'm putting on a music
festival in Henryetta, Oklahoma,
where I'm from.
It is a small town.
It's 4,000 people and
I've got a whole lineup.
It's a one day event and I've
got a number of great artists,
but I needed an Oklahoma headliner.
And so I've been around
Blake a couple of times.
He did a United Way event
that I was a part of years ago in Dallas.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I texted him and said,
"Hey, Blake, I'm putting
on this music festival.
"I need an Oklahoma headliner
"and you're my number one choice."
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And within 10 minutes, Kelly,
he replied back, "I'm in.
"I'm in."
(audience clapping)
- He's the nicest guy.
- He has been unbelievable.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's June 11th,
highwaytohenryetta.com,
If you wanna go to the show.
- Highway to Henryetta,
that's catchy, okay.
- It's, yeah, it's fantastic.
So, we're gonna put Henryetta on the map.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And I say we,
Blake Shelton is gonna
put Henryetta on the map
and I couldn't be happier.
(audience clapping)
- I know, we mess with each
other but he's the nicest guy.
- The best.
- So I'm not shocked at all.
- He's been amazing.
- Yeah, yeah..
Don't tell him I said this, though.
- I won't (laughs).
- He doesn't watch my show, he won't know.
(laughing)And if you're
watching, I'm lying.
(both laughing)
So you also just launched, okay,
a new, low calorie beer.
- [Troy] Yeah.
- It's called Eight.
(audience clapping)
- I feel like I need to test it.
- [Troy] Yes.
- I feel like that's what's gonna happen.
- I feel like it's rude,
if you bring alcohol and
I'm not gonna try, oh.
(audience member laughing)
Here's the thing.
- How great is that?
- Here's the thing, I'm
not usually a beer girl.
That's really good.
- It's good, yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
It tastes clean.
I don't know why that's
the word I'm saying,
but it tastes really nice.
- Well, you know, I worked
for a beer distributor
when I was in college, and I
I've drank my share of beer
but I never imagined that
I'd be making my beer.
But I met my now partners,
through a mutual friend
and we wanted to do a low carb beer.
What's unique about Eight,
is that there's no
adjuncts and no fillers.
- Which is awesome.
And it's the only widely
known available beer,
that I'm aware of, that
can stake that claim.
No sugars, no corn.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No syrup, you know...
- Maybe that's why it
tastes like really light
and it's fresh.
- It's a hundred percent organic grains.
I refer to it as a better-for-you beer.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I think Blake Sheldon
and I are gonna love it.
(audience clapping)
- Well, he is a beer person (laughing).
- (laughing) Yes he is.
- [Kelly] He's like, he
likes beer and vodka.
- [Troy] He has been sent some so, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm sure he took it and drank it.
(laughter)
So wait, while I have you here,
I should know how to throw football.
Now, I feel like I
learned when I was a kid,
but I don't know if I'm doing it right.
So since you're here,
and so I will have bragging
rights to all of my friends
and family.
- [Troy] Absolutely.
- Will you teach me?
- 100%.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, okay.
Okay, let's do it.
Let's do it, I'm so excited.
I think I know how, but I don't know.
My first question..
These are gigantic.
- They are?
- I don't remember them being this...
This is huge.
Okay, wait.
So I feel like, don't you have a...
See, you don't hold it...
- [Troy] I hold it a little differently.
- You hold yours differently.
- I hold it differently.
- Wait, why?
- It's just the way it's
always worked for me, but..
- [Kelly] You like the
texture on your hand?
- You can't hold it the way I hold.
- I heard you're supposed
to have your finger..
Is that right?
- Yeah.
Normally most quarterbacks
would hold it more like this.
- [Kelly] I can't, my hand is so small.
- [Troy] We have three fingers on
the laces.
- [Kelly] The laces, yeah.
- I barely have one.
I hold it way back here
on the back of the ball.
- Yeah, but look at your hand and mine.
- [Troy] I got big hands.
- [Kelly] Yeah (laughing).
- I got big hands.
- You can say it, that's gigantic.
So I can do that.
I can't hold it in either way,
but how do you...
Thought you were supposed to let it spin.
- [Troy] I thought you were an athlete.
- I'm totally an athlete.
- You don't spin.
You know just throw it, spin it.
- Spin it off the tips, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Now what's gonna be embarrassing
is if I miss and you hit.
(laughter and cheering)
- Not for me (laughing).
- Cause I haven't..
I literally have not throw
a ball in quite a while.
- I am looking so forward to this.
Oh gosh, there's no
way I'm gonna hit that.
Are you good at carnival games? I'm not.
- Not bad.
- Okay, oh go ahead.
- You want me to go?
- Yeah, go show me how.
(tins clattering)
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
I feel like I should be able to get closer
but I'm gonna try from here,
here I go.
- Okay.
- Okay, okay, okay, okay.
(drums rumbling)
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
(tins clattering)
No, wait.
- You did it, you did it (laughing).
(cymbals clanging)
(audience cheering)
- Troy Aikman everybody.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.